let me talk briefly about pat robertson
pat robertson declared that donald trump
was the clear winner of sunday night's
presidential debate and he seems to
kinda like trump's [ __ ] gate leaked
audio saying hey this is macho stuff
this is something that we like let's
take a look at video from pat robertson
700 club well interesting ladies and
gentlemen what happened but nevertheless
Trump was the wonderingly the pundits
were writing him off I mean let's face
it a guy does something 11 years ago
as a conversation in Hollywood where
he's trying to look like he's macho and
11 years after that the surfaces from
the Washington Post or whatever bring it
out within 30 days or so of the election
and this is supposed to be the the death
blow and everybody writes him off okay
he's dead now you better get out of the
way and let Mike Pence run the campaign
and the novel says no but as I say he's
like the Phoenix he they think he's dead
he's come back and he came back strong
so he won that debate the next one we'll
see what happens but in the meantime he
speaks to adoring thousands wherever he
goes
and thousands won't win you the
presidential election sadly I don't know
Pat Robertson knows the population in
this country uh did so it's insane that
the self-proclaimed evangelical moral
Christian leader Pat Robertson says that
Trump is a candidate that should even be
remotely appealing to Christians but
what's interesting rachel is that not at
not all Christians agree with this
Franklin grab Billy Graham's
organization recently put out an op-ed
saying there's nothing Christian at all
about Donald Trump's campaign so Pat
Robertson even among the Christian
voices seems to be an outlier that likes
Trump he is but he's also a hypocrite
because oh yeah yeah because in 98 when
the Monica Lewinsky scandal happened
with Bill Clinton he said that Bill
Clinton should be impeached right and
then he went on to say he had turned the
Oval Office into some sort of sexual
playpen for a poster child of the 1960s
which quite frankly doesn't even really
make that much sense to me no it doesn't
make sense to anybody right and this is
also the same man who Ridge
he said he understands if someone wants
to divorce their spouse if they have
Alzheimer's although he later retracted
it yeah he retracted it because it was
just bad PR for saying it I don't know
that is if you actually changed on that
uh you know it's it's shocking to me
that pat robertson is standing behind
trump not because pat robertson tends to
support republicans but more because pat
robertson tends to just go christian
values above all else and uh that this
this is just so clearly the furthest
thing from what pat robertson claims to
support that it's i'm actually somewhat
genuinely surprised pat really he should
be one of the people that are jumping
off the Trump train I guess yeah and
supporting Mike Pence cuz Mike Pence is
seeing much more as a religious values
kind of guy you would benefit that from
that and that pence of course would have
a much better chance at this point of
winning the election and Trump would I
would have expected Pat to say Pence is
the moral Christian good guy and that's
really that is which is which is insane
by the way racing in a slightly
different way and because pence was also
quoted saying that he likes to spend
some time on his knees every day yeah
that's uh that's that's something yeah